this video is kindly sponsored by star
trek fleet command the free to play
multiplayer open world strategy game
that's available on both ios and android
by using my link in the description
below
hey 42 here we humans have long been
fascinated by conspiracy theories and
fringe beliefs according to a 2019
yougov survey more than 10 percent of
americans think the moon landing was
faked
around 20 think climate change is a hoax
and almost 30 percent think the
government is hiding aliens inside area
51.
but whilst it's easy to poke fun at
people who think the earth is flat or
that queen elizabeth ii is actually a
lizard
it turns out that many of the more out
there fringe beliefs are starting to be
taken extremely seriously not just by
tin foil hat wearing maniacs but by some
of the world's most powerful people in
2017 the new york times published an
article revealing that a u.s
government-sponsored secret program had
been studying ufos since 2007. that in
itself was surprising but what was even
more surprising was the fact that this
program had obtained footage of genuine
ufos
[Applause]
not flying sources piloted by little
green men necessarily
but strange fast-moving airborne objects
the pentagon simply had no explanation
for in a report published in june of
this year the u.s government admitted
they couldn't rule out the possibility
that these unidentified aerial phenomena
as they called them
might be of alien origin
star trek fleet command gives you the
opportunity to engage in a story-driven
star trek galaxy in this real-time
combat open world you can battle
alongside your allies to capture
territory pull resources and dominate
the universe
you can craft your perfect ship and
unlock unique ship models and upgrades
you can recruit officers and discover
characters like spock kirk and more you
can build bases and upgrade your space
station you can research that lets you
specialize your fleet and you can become
a freelancer where you can independently
travel the open world playing by your
own rules i've been absolutely loving
playing this game recently and for me
the best part is the high intensity
space battles and the quality of the
graphics is just insane look at all the
incredible detail on this space station
star trek fleet command is free to play
on ios and android using my link in the
description below so what are you
waiting for start building your dream
crew of iconic characters and starships
today
both the new york times article and the
june report mark a seismic shift in the
way controversial topics like ufos are
being perceived by world governments
what were one subjects of ridicule are
suddenly being taken very seriously
indeed but this shift in perception
didn't happen overnight and the chain of
events leading up to it was initiated
almost 15 years ago on a castle farm in
utah with a strange name
and an even stranger reputation
skin walker ranch is a 500 acre property
in the northeast of utah where
over the years some truly disturbing
things have taken place
the ranch is named for a shape-shifting
witch out of navajo folklore that's said
to be able to take on the form of
various animals
but it wasn't the skin walker itself
that first put this ranch on the map
it was ufos
the sightings started way back in the
1950s and they've continued ever since
with literally hundreds of people
claiming to have seen strange lights and
unidentified objects in the skies over
the ranch
but the mystery of skinwalker ranch
doesn't end with ufos in fact that isn't
even the half of it
because when the sherman family bought
the property in 1994
things started to get really weird
within their first few days living at
skinwalker ranch an enormous wolf
attacked one of the sherman's prized
cattle
terry sherman the man of the house was
an experienced castle rancher he was
used to encounters with wolves and so he
calmly pulled out his handgun and shot
the animal at point-blank range
but the wolf did not as terry had
expected collapsed twitching to the
ground in a pool of blood and wolf
brains
nor did it turn tail and flea
in fact
it didn't even seem to take notice
after being shot a further six times
the wolf did eventually decide to go and
look for its dinner elsewhere but terry
sherman's barrage of bullets
hardly seemed to have affected it at all
the shermans would go on to see many
other strange creatures on the property
over the following months
including giant bigfoot like bipeds and
exotic birds that didn't show up in any
books
the sherman's eldest son who i assume
hated the american pie films with a
furious passion had an encounter with an
oddly indistinct creature that seemed to
be able to cloak like the predator
before long the sherman's castle started
disappearing
often never to be seen again
the ones that did turn up were usually
dead with the carcasses drained of blood
and random internal organs removed
the castle weren't mutilated were
pestered by strange balls of light that
zipped around the property like they
owned the place
if any of the family tried to scare
these odd orbs away they experienced
intense psychological symptoms
confusion blurred vision and intense
fear
there were ghostly encounters too
poltergeist activity pervaded the
ranch's many buildings and several
family members reported hearing
disembodied voices
perhaps unsurprisingly considering the
history of the area the shermans also
claimed to have seen plenty of strange
things above the ranch as well as on it
in fact ufos rocked off at skinwalker on
such a regular basis the family were
able to recognize three specific types
a small cube-shaped craft an elongated
ship about 10 meters long
and a truly enormous vessel hundreds of
meters across
the shermans endured this barrage of
bizarre phenomena for close to 18 months
before one final incident pushed them
over the edge
one of those odd blue orbs showed up
near the ranch's main building and
assuming the disembodied light was up to
no good terry sherman sent his free dogs
to chase it off the hounds followed the
orb into some nearby scrub
and sure enough it never came back
but neither did the dogs
terry heard several frantic pained yelps
then silence
their bodies were never found
apparently deciding there might be nicer
places to invest in real estate the
sherman's promptly put the ranch up for
sale you might be thinking that
convincing someone to buy skin walker
ranch would be pretty tricky but it
turns out the perfect buyer lived not
too far away in neighboring nevada
robert bigelow who today has a net worth
somewhere in the region of a billion
dollars snapped up skinwalker ranch
almost as soon as it went on the market
you see whilst bigelow had made his
money first in real estate and later in
aerospace his true passion lay with ufos
and the paranormal
to that end he'd set up the national
institute for discovery science the
previous year
an organization founded to research all
things unexplained as far as robert
bigelow was concerned skinwalker rant
was the perfect place to start
after all where better to prove the
existence of aliens and other worldly
creatures than on a ranch where they
turned up so often you could reasonably
expect to be on first name terms with
bigfoot within days
bigelow and his associates studied
skinwalker ranch intensely for some
eight years before eventually shutting
the project down when paranormal
activity at the ranch decreased but
three years later a senior scientist
from the defense intelligence agency a
governmental organization specializing
in military intelligence
reached out to bigelow with a request
the scientists had heard some strange
things about skinwalker ranch and he
wanted to come and see them for himself
it took a single visit to convince the
man that something outside the realms of
our understanding inhabited this ranch
within hours of arriving he saw a
strange fluctuating shape appear in
mid-air the object whatever it was
flickered and undulated before him
taking on the form of a multi-coloured
mobius strip
before blinking out of existence
this encounter at skinwalker ranch
directly led to pentagon approval for
the 22 million dollar advanced aerospace
threat identification program in
behind the somewhat opaque name the
purpose of this organization was clear
to investigate ufos the program was
terminated five years later but was
eventually succeeded by the less
ambiguously named unidentified aerial
phenomena task force
the very same program that recently
confirmed the us government is in the
process of studying genuine ufos
now i have to admit all of this is
pretty compelling i mean we're talking
about hundreds of strange sightings at
skinwalker ranch over the space of seven
decades or so sightings that were
convincing enough to get the us
government to invest millions of dollars
into ufo research
there is one tiny issue though
the elephant that isn't in the room if
you will
skimwalker ranch is undoubtedly one of
the most intensely studied ufo cryptid
and paranormal sites on planet earth
and yet
not one single piece of hard evidence
exists
that proves any of the phenomena people
claim to have witnessed there
no ufos have been filmed streaking
across the sky overhead no giant wolves
of unknown species have been captured no
strange balls of light have been
photographed screwing around with cattle
or evaporating loyal dogs
nothing
in more than 70 years
now i know what you're thinking if the
government really has found proof of the
paranormal at skinwalker ranch they're
hardly going to tell us plebs about it
and that may well be true but it isn't
just a us government that's gone to
skimwalker ranch looking for ghosts
there have been literally hundreds
possibly thousands of sightings there
over the years by perfectly ordinary
people and not once has anyone captured
anything
on camera
the history channel recently shot an
entire tv series there
meaning a large group of people spent
several months on the site armed with
high-tech cameras rolling day and night
and they recorded
precisely nothing
admittedly they did try really hard to
make that nothing look a bit like
something but ultimately beneath the bad
acting and the truly terrible scientific
experiments they didn't find or film
anything inexplicable at all
some people believe whatever it is that
lurks on the ranch is far too smart to
be caught on film by us idiot humans
and hey maybe that's the case
it sounds kind of reasonable in
principle
but how would that actually work in
practice
do all the flashing lights ufos and
strange creatures that have been spotted
around skinwalker ranch
come pre-installed with some kind of
hyper-sensitive human holding the camera
radar that warns them whenever someone
reaches into his pocket for an iphone is
it really realistic to believe that the
unknown intelligence behind these
phenomena is happy to be seen by humans
but not be filmed
if so why
now don't get me wrong i'm not saying
there's definitely nothing going on at
skinwalker ranch
there are plenty of gaps in our
understanding of the universe and until
we 100
that really hard video game called
science
it's impossible to rule anything out for
sure
but might there be something else going
on at skinwalker ranch that explains all
this weirdness without the need for
ghosts and goblins
well
maybe
skinwalker ranch's reputation is built
on eyewitness reports made by people
who've seen things in the area they
can't explain
on the plus side there are lots of these
reports but on the downside
we humans are as a rule terrible
eyewitnesses
like really terrible unreliable
eyewitnesses are thought to be behind a
frankly scary three quarters of all
false convictions in murder and rape
cases in the uk and an equally
frightening 70
of all wrongful convictions overturned
by dna evidence in the us if you've been
following the channel for a while you'll
also know that humans are prone to
forming false memories about things that
never happened
misleading memories that are
indistinguishable from genuine ones
so whilst hundreds of eyewitness
accounts certainly can't be written off
they also don't actually prove anything
and don't forget most people go to
skinwalker ranch because they've heard
the stories and want to see the monsters
and ufos for themselves
which in itself probably goes a fair way
to explaining
why there have been so many sightings
motivated perception
where our motivations impact how we see
the world is a well-studied phenomenon
broadly speaking motivated perception
means that people see what they want to
see
anyone going to skin walker ranch hoping
even expecting to see ufos or
bulletproof wolves
is much more likely to do exactly that
than a random tourist strolling through
the area with no preconceived ideas
about what he might find there
but what about the sherman family
they seem to have had run-ins with ufos
and creepy cryptids
on an almost daily basis
surely all of that can't be down to some
kind of mass trick of motivational
perception
no probably not
but then again it probably isn't
entirely reasonable to conclude that
aliens
unkillable werewolves intelligent balls
of light poltergeists and bigfoot all
definitely exist because one family says
they do if i was to tell you i ride to
work every morning on a flying horse
called biggles
you'd probably have your reservations
or maybe not
and if the sherman family really did see
strange things as often as they claimed
to
you'd think they might have managed to
catch something on camera of course it's
perfectly possible very likely even that
plenty of people who've experienced
strange things on skinwalker ranch are
completely reliable witnesses who were
not all mistaken in what they saw or
felt but seeing or feeling something you
can't explain doesn't automatically mean
aliens or interdimensional beings are
responsible for it
plenty of apparent bigfoot sightings
over the years are thought to have been
caused by black bears walking on their
hind legs
and many supposed ufo encounters have
turned out to be the cases of mistaken
identity with things like weather
balloons satellite arrays meteorites or
military tests involving experimental
weapons and aircraft that last one is
particularly interesting by the way
because the deserts of utah have long
been a favorite location for classified
u.s military tests
skinwalker ranch is just 150 miles from
dugway proving ground a military test
site that many ufologists consider to be
some kind of successor to area 51.
so
what's really going on at skinwalker
ranch the truth is there's no way to
know for sure well carl sagan once said
that extraordinary claims require
extraordinary evidence
and i'm inclined to agree
if you were to tell me you saw a monkey
in full hells angels regalia fleeing
from the police on the back of a flaming
harley-davidson you'd better have some
seriously compelling footage to back it
up
as of today there is no such compelling
footage or any other concrete evidence
for that matter supporting the idea that
skinwalker ranch is some kind of
convention center for possibly made-up
things that scare the crap out of humans
it's certainly interesting that the u.s
government briefly took an interest in
the site but then again rumor has it the
cia once hired yuri geller to erase kgb
floppy disks using the power of his
spoon bending mind so yeah
that's no guarantee of anything either
whilst there's no denying skimwalker
ranch it's a strange and intriguing
place for now if you want to believe
it's regularly frequented by aliens
giant wolves bigfoot poltergeist and dog
devouring balls of light
you're going to have to take a leap of
faith
incidentally robert bigelow sold
skinwalker ranch in 2016 to a shady
shell corporation known as adamantium
holdings
the price
4.5 million dollars
turns out you can make a fair bit of
cash if you manage to convince someone
you own the alien equivalent of mecca
thanks for watching
good news you can now pre-order my new
book bread and circuses what did the
romans ever do for us it's a wild and
witty journey for a thousand years of
unexpected roman history
told in a refreshing way and packed full
of incredible and unbelievable stories
copies are selling out fast so pre-order
yours today to lock it in thank you